we start with some signs of Ukrainian
forces gaining ground and pushing back
Russian forces intelligence Reports say
Ukraine has retaken ground west of Kiev
and destroyed a ship in russian-held
territory when Russia launched its
Invasion a month ago it expected to take
Ukraine in a lightning offensive Against
All Odds Ukrainian forces continue to
keep one of the world's biggest armies
at Bay but that resistance has come at a
terrible price
flames and smoke billowing from a
Russian transport ship in the harbor of
Russian occupied bergansk
lines for humanitarian AIDS stretching
in front of bombed out apartment blocks
in the heavily struck city of mariupole
a month into Russia's war in Ukraine
every day is full of images that only
weeks ago were difficult if not
impossible to imagine in modern Europe
the Sun was shining in Kiev and no bombs
were falling for the moment as soldiers
and civilians reflected on a month of
War
ukrainians have United as never before
perhaps this makes me very happy and the
Russians made a big mistake coming after
our country our land we will bite their
throats it's our homeland
morale is as high as on the first day
and it will remain so until the last day
Victory Day we remain determined
Ukraine has proven its resilience but
sustained bombardment bodies in the
streets and life in bomb shelters with
limited or no power or heat are bound to
take their toll on even the bravest
I feel hopelessness one doesn't know
what to do next how to behave
I try to keep calm and only hope that
everything will be over and all will be
fine as it was before and to see the
smiles return to people's faces and our
chances to enjoy life return to us
a month ago no one knew how long Ukraine
could hold out against Russia
and yet despite the toll to human life
and infrastructure and the sheer size of
the Russian war machine the underdog is
still standing
we can speak now to our correspondent
funny fajar she's reporting from Viv in
Western Ukraine hi funny we saw in that
report that about Ukraine's reported a
sinking of a Russian Supply ship tell us
more about what that means
there's several Landing ships that of
course want to supply the Russians with
very important uh
basically things that you need to fight
in this war we are talking about fuel
we're talking about armored vehicles
we're talking about supplies and Ukraine
claims that they sank one of these ships
a landing ship named orsk near the
Oporto town berdians which by the way is
about 85 kilometers from besieged town
of Mario Paul now also Ukraine claims
are that they could make some Headway in
Kiev as well in the northern part of the
city and push back some of the Russian
troops we cannot verify that but the
videos that we have seen about the
apparent destruction of that ship of
course symbolizes to many people here on
the ground that some Headway is being
made and that the offensive by Ukrainian
forces also succeeds in some way even
though of course it cannot be
underestimated that Russia is still very
Superior in terms of the number of
troops and the military and any other
elements that they have to bring forward
what they call is a demilitarization and
denotification education of Ukraine
so they're making a Headway funny you
said but is there a sense there that
Ukrainian forces are actually gaining
the upper hand
that's a really good question because
there are mixed messages in a way on the
one hand the Ukraine Indian defense
Ministry says said yesterday that they
made some progress as I say in Keith in
the northern part and some of the troops
could be pushed back at the same time of
course the troops the Russian troops
are known to then again come together
regroup and to try to start the
offensive again in fact Ukraine said
that they do know that his offensives
are going to resume not only in Keith
but also in harkif and Sumi and other
parts of Ukraine also in Mario Paul
really a town where you ask yourself
what is there to resume because that
town is basically reduced to almost
nothing and the people who are trapped
there even the ones who are trying to
leave that City are asking themselves
where to go to so yes on one hand
Ukraine is trying to spread this message
that we we let's hang in there because
we also are going to make some progress
Ukrainian military is going to make some
progress here the question is though
what Ukraine is going to look like by
that time when that progress according
to Ukraine is completed and at what
price funny we know that the toll on the
civilian population has been devastating
hasn't it
definitely unfortunately with four weeks
into this wall thousands of people have
been killed and unfortunately we can
only talk about an estimate as it's
really incredibly hard just to verify
the numbers as they are talents where
even journalists do not have or just
very limited access to so we need to
work with the sources that we have from
beat ngos United Nations and can only
call it an estimate but bottom line is
millions of people have been displaced
since the War Began and are going to
continue to be displaced as long as this
massacre actually as the pope called it
a senseless Massacre continues as the
war continues
DW's funny fatal reporting from leviv
thank you for that update
and we can get some more perspective now
with halina vaselchenko she is a member
of the Ukrainian Parliament Miss
vasochenko thank you for joining us here
on DW the war as we mentioned has now
entered its second month can you tell us
more about what your experience has been
yeah hello thank you for inviting and
thank you that you showed to all the
world what is really going on in Ukraine
and of course this is the worst time in
our history because in our history since
we are independent uh you see what is
going on and every day these miles are
firing our cities and the worst is that
these Russian soldiers they don't fight
with our soldiers they fight with our
civilians and you see what they made
with Marion Paul with uh what they made
with our big cities such as harkive
Chinese and so on they um
they are fighting hospitals they are
fighting residential buildings as they
are fighting
um different administrative our
administrative buildings and houses they
have destroy they had destroyed more
than 500 educational and educational
buildings such as schools and
kinderganders we've just been as you've
been speaking Miss vasenchenko we've
been looking there at some of the
pictures of the devastation in mariupo
that you yourself have just been
mentioning I want to ask you about the
day of diplomacy and Summits that we saw
in Brussels we saw a NATO of course
vowed to continue to support Ukraine we
saw EU member states say that as well
but they rule out direct intervention
and they rule out any sort of Step that
might result in an engagement with
Russia are you disappointed in what
you've seen from Western Ally so far
first of all I want to say to say thank
you to all governments and to all people
around the world that are supporting us
and for the for all that military and of
humanitarian Aid is that we are gaining
from EU members and from the United
States of America but I'm sure that for
instance NATO for instance the United
States of America and also EU members
they can more because for as for this
moment we are not only defending our
country and only our democracy we are
defending democracy and
democracy of the whole Humanity of the
whole civil civilized world we are
defending democracy of the whole Europe
and NATO as you mentioned it was created
as the most safe aliens aliens for
safety in the world and we ask to take
us to Nato and we are sure that if we
were a member of NATO this war could not
be launched and even for this moment we
are sure that our soldiers at our army
meets the standards of the NATO well
what do you think of the fact of the
concerns from NATO member states that
taking Ukraine in as a member for
example could raise the threat of a
nuclear war
I think that
um for these last weeks everyone in the
world understood that Putin is crazy and
if he will decide to for instance to use
chemical biological or nuclear war or to
to start mobile the world he will do it
despite uh are we the members of NATO or
not whether for instance peacekeepers
are in Ukraine or not
if you could send one message to Nato
and to the EU of what you need right now
in Ukraine what would it be
we need to close the sky and we need
peacekeepers here in Ukraine
we'll leave it there remember the
Ukrainian Parliament Helena vaselchenko
thank you very much for joining us on DW
this morning
thank you
and our Brussels bureau chief Alexander
phenomen has been covering all the
action for us hi Alexander it's good to
see you tell us more about what came out
of this flurry of activity in Brussels
also made the fact that all the three
summits took place on one day he in
Brussels was remarkable and a strong
sign of unity with NATO leaders
approving a massive reinforcements of
the alliance's forces on the Eastern
flank and promising more military
assistance to Ukraine with the G7
leaders saying that they will hamper any
efforts to circumvent Western sanctions
and the European leaders meeting with
the U.S president and calling out Russia
for its war crimes and promising Ukraine
to raise money to help rebuild the
country however when we talk about
concrete outcome that was rather limited
and of course not enough from the
Ukrainian perspective NATO is still
saying no to a no-fly zone over Ukraine
and the EU leaders has rebuffed Ukraine
Ukraine's plea for a fast track EU
membership and that is a message we
heard directly from the Ukrainian
president he thanked EU members West for
their support but also was critical of
what they have not done so let's take a
look at what he said
you've applied sanctions
and we're grateful
these are powerful steps but it was a
little late
because if it was preventive Russia
would not have gone to war
no one knows for sure but at least there
was a chance
so Alexander zielinski essentially
saying there that Western leaders
enabled Putin's invasion of Ukraine how
did that go down in Brussels
well I think that we have to acknowledge
we have to acknowledge that zielinski
has emerged as a as an excellent
Communicator who is tailoring his
messages to the audience he's facing and
that was the case here as well and I
think that it went down well with some
member states with the Baltic states for
instance or Poland they have been
calling on the EU to be tougher on
Russia for years they are pushing for
more sanctions more action to help
Ukraine and the Linsky acknowledged that
in his statement saying Latvia stands
with us Lithuania stands with us and
then he went on speaking about Germany
for instance and he said that Germany a
little bit later acknowledging that
Germany was initial initially reluctant
to imposing tougher sanctions and the
Germany is now one of the member states
that are blocking a potential oil and
natural gas embargo
Alexander tells more about what is
happening today we saw President Biden
calling for Russia to be kicked out of
the G20 and we understand there's going
to be an announcement as well about
boosting U.S gas shipments to the EU
yes and um the U.S president was very
clear that it it were if it were for him
he would remove Russia from the G20 but
of course he knows that it needs to be a
consensus-based a decision in some G20
members are reluctant to remove Russia
that is why he suggested that Ukraine
should be invited to the G20 meetings
we'll see whether that is going to
happen and today we expect a joint
statement by the European Union and the
U.S on energy with the US expected to
promise to deliver up to 15 billion
cubic meters of liquefied natural gas to
the European Union until the end of this
year to help the EU be less dependent on
liquefied natural gas from Russia
tw's Brussels bureau chief Alexandra
fundaman good to talk to you
countries in the Middle East and North
Africa import most of their wheat from
Russia and Ukraine since the Russian
invasion the price of grain has spiked
threatening food security for millions
of people countries like Tunisia and
Morocco were already vulnerable to food
crises especially in the wake of the
covid-19 pandemic and severe drought but
the added impact of War could lead to
social unrest
a FIFA likes to offer guests a cup of
coffee it's one of the few things she
still has in her kitchen
when we go to a store to buy ingredients
there isn't anything
not even a flower
in many stores in Tunisia the shelves
are empty it's just before Ramadan and
customers are stocking up on Staples
they're worried about shortages
especially during these festive weeks
in Tunisia we import almost 40 percent
of our wheat from Russia and Ukraine and
80 of our flour
many people here do not believe the
government's assurances that supplies
will last for another three months
prices are rising sharply some sellers
think that wholesalers want to profit
from the crisis
there are black marketeers who are
taking advantage of the war in Ukraine
and hoarding Goods there's no semolina
no sugar no flour no cooking oil
Morocco also Imports food Staples from
Russia and Ukraine even a slight
increase in prices can lead to social
tensions the government is trying to
reassure the public
all of the products that are needed
during Ramadan will be available
prices will be closely monitored so that
citizens are not affected
a long drowned eroded the soil in
Morocco to compensate for this the
government has had to set up a special
budget roughly equivalent to 1 billion
euros now the war in Ukraine is adding
to those costs which are hitting the
poor countries of the maghreb
particularly hard